all cultures around the world have told
stories about spooky creatures or forces
that try to explain some of the
mysterious and unexplained aspects of
our world creatures and stories that
often have a function to be educational
and to keep people especially children
from wandering about in strange places
or at night and which will inevitably be
exploited in some crappy Hollywood movie
at some point
in Sweden and the Nordic countries we
have a bunch of these stories and
creatures and one of the most spooky and
scary ones is the creature known as the
mare a ghostly figure that creeps up on
you when you sleep and which most
probably is meant to represent the what
we know today as the dreaded experience
of sleep paralysis
so join me for the first episode of this
year's shocktober as we talk about the
mayor
[Music]
[Music]
the mayor is a creature that has existed
in the folklore of Sweden and its
surrounding countries for a long time
there are even mentions of the mayor in
snory's Ada or the prose Ada written in
the 12th century these stories are of
course probably taken from even older
material and it's likely that the mayor
is a figure that has been around since a
while before the 13th century at least
in Sweden the mayor is called Maran and
she has similar names in surrounding
countries she could be referred to by
many other names as well but modern or
the mayor is the name that seems to have
stuck across history
the etymology of the word Mata is
thought to have originally meant
something like crushing or oppression
which will make sense when we describe
her features but significantly it is
from the mayor that we get the word
nightmare for when we have a bad dream
this connection is present in Swedish as
well where the name for nightmare is
more dram meaning literally mer dream
and indeed the mayor is primarily
associated with sleep and the bedroom
while she can take on many different
forms all stories about the mayor share
the idea that she will somehow creep
into your house at night approach your
bed while you are sleeping and
essentially sit on your chest pretty
creepy stuff as I said the mayor could
take on many different forms usually she
is considered of as a human woman
sometimes dressed in black but many
other times she also takes the form of a
cat a dog or an owl the function was the
same though as it would always show up
in your bedroom and usually sit on your
chest which create a kind of oppressing
kind of a hard feeling of having a hard
time breathing basically there have been
some ideas floating around regarding the
origins or nature of the mare some say a
mer was a woman that had been cursed
somehow that she lived a normal life
during the day but at night would turn
into a frightening creature that invaded
people's homes
other stories relate that she was rather
just an evil person that made a
conscious decision to terrorize people
and it wasn't just people that had to
withstand attacks from the mayor even
animals could fall victim he was often
believed that if the horses on a farm
for example appeared tired and sweaty in
the morning for no apparent reason this
meant that they had been visited by the
mayor during the night the horses would
also sometimes have small braids in
their Mane which would be called mod
flat or mare braids now obviously there
are also sometimes certain erotic
aspects to this Legend some stories say
that the mayor was primarily driven by
jealousy and a desire to be close to men
particularly in southern Sweden there
was a widespread belief that a mayor was
in fact the spirit of an unmarried dead
woman there are even stories about
people who married a mayor there is a
story about a person a guy who is
visited by this creature and then
basically blocks off all exits to the
house so she so he traps the mare in his
house basically and then forces her to
to marry him essentially not that I
recommend anyone to do this but that is
one such story in any case stories about
visitations from the mayor are usually
pretty similar she will enter your
bedroom and sit on your chest
people experience that they have trouble
breathing because of the huge pressure
on their chest as well as the sensation
of being paralyzed so not being able to
move now obviously this can be pretty
safely connected to a known condition
today that we call sleep paralysis
many people myself included have
experienced waking up in the middle of
the night unable to move many also
experienced that pressure on the chest
that is often described in the stories
and some also experience hallucinations
of actually seeing figures standing over
you or sitting on your chest as a result
of the brain not quite having broken up
yet it could be a truly terrifying
experience especially if you're not used
to it and indeed for those of us who
have experienced sleep paralysis you
could say that we have been visited by
the mayor because it's clear that the
stories about the mayor is a way to
explain or or to personify this rather
common condition that people have
experienced historically and still
experience today right it's a way to
sort of explain this condition by
pointing to a a supernatural creature
that somehow personifies it and not just
sleep paralysis but basically any bad
dream was seen as being caused by the
Mare and that is why it's called a
nightmare so any bad dream is the mayor
that is visiting you and causing this
bad dream and that should make you look
twice across the room the next time you
wake up in the middle of the night
possibly because these experiences and
conditions such as sleep paralysis are
so common there are many stories and
accounts from around the Nordic
countries of people encountering a mare
in one account from 1873 in eastern
Sweden a woman tells us quote back home
in Husby people believe the mayor was a
living person that was jealous
than the jealous person could visit the
one she wanted to hurt there was an old
lady close to where I lived in Husby who
complained to my mother that the mayor
was terrorizing her at night that she
would come floating in through the
chamber door even though it was locked
she would recognize her as one of her
neighbors who would then lie on her
chest so she couldn't breathe
in another account from 1864 quote the
mayor would bother both humans and
animals it was a spirit that comes over
you when you sleep it lies across your
chest and it feels like something hairy
just a few years ago I myself was
looking through the archives in a local
Museum here in Stockholm and I came
across an old report from a village or
region in Western Sweden a small village
where we usually spend our summers and
I'm probably grown up there and so on
and this was a report from like early
last century that basically said that
multiple people had spotted the mayor in
that Village which you know might have
felt better if I didn't see that before
going that summer anyway the mayor shows
up all across this region of Europe and
appears quite common it's a pretty
creepy creature that most people would
want to keep away so how does one
protect oneself from the mayor well
there are several traditions and stories
about this too depending on what region
you are in ETC obviously in Christian
times you could do things like hang up
crucifix over your bed or keep a copy of
the Bible or a song book under your
pillow or next to the bed so aside from
this you should avoid going to bed on a
full stomach you could put horseshoes
under your bed or sing protective songs
that often tell the mayor to count
various things before attacking you see
it was believed that she was really bad
at math and giving her a task to for
example count all the trees in the
forest first meant that she wouldn't
have time to attack before morning
arrived some traditions also state that
you can cure a mare now this only works
in those cases where the mayor was
thought to be a living cursed human
being of course but since the person in
question didn't know that she was a
mayor during the night you could tell
her often in the moment when she returns
to her body so when the marriage out
during the night haunting people in
their sleep eventually in the morning
the mayor will return to her home to her
regular sort of body and Consciousness
and if you tell the mayor at the very
moment where she sort of reunites with
her body that should for some reason
cure her and she will return to just
being her normal self as you can tell
and as is usually the case with things
like this in terms of folklore and
mythology and religion there are there's
a diversity of stories and ideas about
the mayor depending on which region you
are in there are different conceptions
of what the mayor looked like what her
function was and of course also across
time things and these stories will will
change inevitably but there are a few
things that always remain
associated with the mayor for one thing
that she is really creepy but also
certain other characteristics like
visiting you at night in your bedroom
and sitting on your chest the fact that
we can kind of confirm that most or at
least many of these stories are real
because they are most likely based on
the common and real experience of sleep
paralysis makes it all the more
fascinating and kind of also all the
more spooky and creepy and I definitely
don't look forward to any possible
future episode of sleep paralysis if
there's any possibility that I will run
into this really scary creature but with
that said this is of course another
perfect fit for our yearly shocktober
Series where we discuss the darker and
spookier aspects of religion mythology
folklore and history I hope you are
properly spooked now although not too
much of course and that you are looking
forward to more episodes coming this
month I know I am I have some really
exciting and fun things coming so look
forward to that in the coming weeks and
I will see you then
foreign